Speaker 1: OK, one of the things that we have
been kind of discussing, we I mean me with
many in the audience is how we should react
to the deaths of the unvaccinated or more
specifically, the anti-vaccine individuals,
anti-vaccine individuals who prominently say
we're against the COVID vaccine.
And then they die of COVID.
I get emails all the time from people saying,
David, you really shouldn't gloat about anti-vaxxers
dying.
And I agree.
I don't gloat about anti-vaxxers dying.
I've said time and again, I feel terribly
about people who have been misled into thinking
the vaccine is a bad thing.
And then they get COVID and then they die
and their family members grieve, and it's
sad.
I don't gloat about it, but this is super
interesting.
There's a column in the Los Angeles Times
by Michael Hiltzik, which says we should be
mocking anti-vaxxer deaths, and it is a fascinating
read.
We will link to it and I encourage you to
look at it.
Michael writes Among all the ways that COVID
affects our lives, the pandemic confronts
us with a profound moral dilemma.
How should we react to the deaths of the unvaccinated?
On the one hand, a hallmark of civilized thought
is the sense that every life is precious.
On the other, those who have deliberately
flouted that's not flaunted.
Remember, that's a word flouted sober medical
advice by refusing a vaccine known to reduce
the risk of serious disease from the virus,
including the risk to others and end up in
the hospital or the grave can be viewed as
receiving their just desserts.
That's even more true of those who not only
refuse the vaccine for themselves, but publicly
advocated that others do so.
It has become common online and in social
media for vaccine refusers and anti-vaccine
advocates to become the target of ridicule
after they come down with COVID and especially
if they die from it.
Witness the subreddit Herman Cain Award.
The site is named for the former Republican
candidate for president, who became one of
the first political notables to succumb to
the disease after publicly defying social
distancing measures like another site sorry,
anti-vaxxer.
The subreddit hosts snippets and photographs
of anti-vaccine advocates often taken at their
death beds.
The issue of how to think about the deaths
of unvaccinated has been thrown into high
relief locally by the case of Kelly earned
B..
Remember, we covered that that's the Orange
County Republican who was against the mandates
and died of COVID unvaccinated earned.
Bee's death promptly came to symbolize the
rift in the social fabric caused by the ravages
of COVID.
And then it goes on to say that some of what
is happening with her is bigotry and hate.
Michael Hiltzik has a different take.
He says to begin with, let's stipulate not
all unvaccinated people are alike.
Some are unvaccinated for legit medical reasons.
Children for whom the COVID vaccines haven't
been ruled safe for someone with a real medical
reason, some may have faced obstacles in getting
to a vaccination site.
Others may have been may have refused the
vaccine because they've been deceived by Fox
News or whatever else.
The deaths are truly lamentable.
Finally, there are those who have voiced public
opposition to the vaccines.
Not all of whom are unvaccinated themselves
earned.
Irn-Bru was in that category.
She asserted opposition not to vaccines but
to mandates, and Hiltzik goes on to say it
should be clear that opposing vaccine mandates
as a as a substitute for opposing vaccination
itself is a fundamentally incoherent position.
It's little more than the garden variety small-government
Republican ideology.
Hiltzik points out the significantly lower
vaccination rate of Republicans and says mandates
do work requirements that people provide evidence
of vaccination have been associated with heightened
vaccine rates.
As for whether vaccination mandates are a
slippery slope to more government control,
which many of these people maintain, government
mandates for vaccines have been with us for
decades and for other kinds wearing seatbelts,
having airbags in cars, banning smoking in
public places, and that these mandates exist
because the diseases threaten not only the
infected people but also the community.
And Hiltzik goes on to say ultimately that
it is so pernicious that we have these people
around advocating against vaccines are against
vaccine mandates that in fact, we should be
ridiculing them, that in fact we should be
mocking them and that in the long run, even
though it feels like a ghoulish thing to do
the same way that vaccine mandates work, mocking
those who are anti-vax, outspokenly anti-vax
or anti mandate and then die actually is effective
at getting people vaccinated.
That it might feel wrong, as I have said,
and many of you have said, but that it is
actually a necessary thing to do because of
the public health consequences.
Check out Michael Hiltzik opinion piece, and
I would love to hear from you about this.
Let me know what
you think.